Ghost Recon wildlands is opening up a
new province in Bolivia for the open
beta fortunately we had a chance to romp
around the province of montiek at a
previous press event and we're here to
get you ready
we like bringing this content to you so
if you like Ghost Recon games keep
voting with those likes and subscribes
and after this video let us know which
of these things you'd like us to
livestream first as soon as the beta
goes live without further ado here are 5
things you should know before firing up
that open beta keep in mind that we
played in earlier build of this area so
some things might change number one
there's a place where you can get an
infantry fighting vehicle and backhoes
and it's right here in the closed beta
we discovered a good assortment of
civilian vehicles several types of
helicopters and a plane totally not full
of drugs but what it didn't have is a
tank like infantry vehicle and backhoes
plural the imagination goes wild with
possibilities but mostly around backhoe
griefing your buddies llamas and the AI
we found a train in the closed beta and
we're ready to find out which ones
tougher my bet is on the train number 2
there's a giant underground military
complex at an abandoned silver mine and
it's one of the coolest things you'll
see in both the closed and open beta
fighting through underground tunnels in
the dark was like something out of a
splinter cell game the mission involves
a rogue US Army Ranger who some on your
team know and have worked with which
might indicate the story could take a
darker turn later on foreshadowing may
be given the writing in the game so far
probably not also killing the boss man
Nets you the m4a1 tactical which we
can't show you until the open beta
starts killing major characters and
wildlands give players legendary guns
ultimately they can't be modded which
honestly I'm not too keen on in the
meantime though we can show you the
legendary his or hers weapons from the
closed beta for me Deadshot stable
number three there's a giant-ass salt
lake with flamingos and sick views as we
stated earlier wild lands is not the
prettiest of games close-up but at a
distance it's gorgeous
this lake is a central feature of this
region and flying over it while watching
flocks of flamingos peel off to avoid
your pop wash is a treat the lake in the
beta is probably laguna colorado or the
red lagoon number four you need a drools
harder and montiek than in the closed
beta region wild lands has an alert
faction system and once you get that
four star rating enemy waves keep coming
until you escape or get dead
so unlock a grenade launcher two down
those helicopters about to rain on your
exit strategy know how to shoot them
down in teams of focused fire or
headshot a pilot through the side window
we also encountered a funny bug where
enemies survived crashing and kept
shooting at us so heads up oh he did
also anti-air launchers are more
abundant in montiek requiring ghost
teams to go on foot and deal with them
first before getting choppered in or out
I recommend you unlock the parachute
because you will get shot down from time
to time
number five new guns to tweak we played
with some new guns the event including
the FAMAS MK 14 and a vector 45 they may
not be in the open beta but we will
scour the map for new weapons and
attachments that have to be retrieved
from weapon crates we've been dying for
a good eight times or 12 times scoped
and we were able to prove in the close
beta that you can use unsuppressed
long-range sniping as a viable strategy
to enhance the gun fun there are no
tanky bosses in the new province we
accidentally killed one with a stray 320
grenade launcher as it should be so far
we're finding wildlands to be a buggy
but fun co-op sandbox if you want to
know more check out the changes we want
and Ghost Recon wildlands after playing
the closed beta video so what's your
game plan for the open beta sound off in
the comments below and as always thanks
for watching
you
[Music]